interesting as you've been following if
you follow this primary that never
seemed to end and now it's finally over
you saw something very interesting
happen when it comes to political stage
crafting Barack Obama has done these
amazing things he can get 70,000 people
to show up and ilan underneath the heat
you know he packed stadiums full and
that really connects to a certain group
of people it connects often he makes
these very lofty speeches and it's there
they're a bit more intellectual yet
heartfelt I mean totally heartfelt
where's Hillary Clinton did retail
politics meaning you know door-to-door
on the ground just like Bill Clinton did
I mean these people really helps define
what that was and so Hillary Clinton
would be down on the hay bales she would
have press conferences at gas stations
she would show up at union halls and she
really understood that the the space is
political just how they say is a
personals political space is political
in and of itself and so as you saw
Hillary begin to gain momentum
especially with working-class voters I
think a lot of it had to do with where
she was connecting with people whereas
Obama was connecting with people in
these large masses and then you saw that
Obama shifted his game a little bit
which was super smart literally he
started playing basketball and having
meetings in basketball halls and he
understanding that you have to get down
on the ground and sometimes roll up your
sleeves and play little hoops and other
times you know give the big speech
I'm going to tell you a little anecdote
about how off i think john mccain is if
you go to John McCain's website right
now in the main property of the main
real estate of the property right so
right in the middle of the homepage
there's four major tabs and I don't
remember exactly what they are but it's
like strategy decision election and then
golf gear golf gear and you talk about
you know we're at a time right now where
the women's vote a lot of its shifting
because there are a lot of women who are
upset about Hillary and they'll say I'm
going to vote for McCain and this guy
has on the front page of his website
golf gear you know personalized McCain
golf gear now that is not going to
attract women voters and it's definitely
not going to attract the blue-collar
voters who the only thing they know
about golf is that rich people do it
he's completely out of touch so whether
it's stagecraft you know with horrible
green colors or whether it's you know
not getting the branding and messaging
right she doesn't have it you know one
of the reasons I think Hillary Clinton
losses she ran a 1992 campaign in 2008
Barack Obama got momentum because they
understood the internet and instead of
going after two thousand dollar donors
or however even whatever the max is one
person at a time he decided to go for a
much grow a much larger donor base at a
hundred dollars at a time and he really
understands modern-day elections it's as
much about the media as it is the
internet and those things are completely
interconnected I mean look at the
Jeremiah Wright thing that thing
exploded on YouTube the whole way that
the campaign campaigns are now it's
completely changed the rules of the game
i'm not sure that mccain gets that
well if I were to give Barack Obama some
advice right now I definitely think that
he is he's connected very much on the
intellectual level with a lot of people
which is wonderful I after having eight
years of the Bush administration I want
intellectual office and I'm really
looking forward to that but I want to
intellectual who comes from who I can
connect with who I feel like came from
where I came from and you know he has
this beautiful story that I think he
needs to tell a little bit more and
that's the story of his mother and the
role that his mother played you know all
of us have mothers and we were all
really shaped by her parents he wrote a
book about his father you know dreams of
his father I think his mother is this
very interesting character and I'm going
to be especially if he wants women to
vote for him I think he's gonna I need
to be respectful of his relationship and
all of that I understand that but I
think the story of his mother if he
brings that out a little bit more that
could be really helpful to him